ça c'est dit ces échecs à ses parents à
ses angoisses et des jo
l'histoire d'amour entre les québécois
et l'humour est notoire mais ce qu'on
fait peut-être moins c'est qu'il existe
aussi une histoire d'amour entre
hollywood et montréal grâce au festival
just for laugh c'est la plus grande du
festival du monde ici à montréal chaque
jour lui est depuis des années c'est
vraiment où les l'inde aussi bien pour
trouver le prochain une grande histoire
en achetant au fil du temps jusqu'à la
fab une être de grands noms de l'humour
génitales and albert même l'actrice amy
chômeurs a fait ses premières armes ou
café cléopâtre pour comprendre la place
qu'a réussi à se tailler ce festival
dans le monde
il faut remonter à sa création en 1985
deux ans après l'arrivée de son grand
frère francophone juste pour rire ça
prend juste une chose une allumette pour
l'ancien feu première des choses andré
philippe gagnon fait son imitation de we
are the world
après une seule prestation au gala
anglophone andré télé gagnon a été
invité sur tous les plateaux de
télévision américains et le monde s'est
répandue dans le monde industriel
américain comme quoi au samarien qu'il
faut aller pour aller déceler des
candidats pour aller défier futur hub
d'air je vais vous conter une anecdote
mais qu il est un grand amateur d'humour
américain à tel point qu'aujourd'hui ils
montent tant sur les planches de juste
pour rire que de just for life works htc
j'aurais aimé donner la mort
juste pour voir le nest et chaud parce
que tu sais là que bill gates est née
c'est là que louis xi qui est née si les
deux solitudes existe à travers les deux
festivals de plus en plus de
francophones s'intéresse à l'humour
américain
ça change beaucoup maintenant c'est pour
certains avec neuf l'excès youtube et
pour certains avec des amateurs plus
jeune je trouve que maintenant il ya
beaucoup plus de français dans notre
salle anglais et la sphère gilbert rozon
à tel compromis la relation entre
hollywood et le québec gilles bail avec
par rapport avec deux solas gilbert
stèle monsieur wild qu'elle est une fois
par année aux parties dire salut aux
américains fêtent les personnes qu'ils
connaissent même avec de nouveaux
propriétaires américains
pas question pour le moment de changer
la recette gagnante qui attire des
milliers de touristes de partout dans le
monde chaque année et c'est jacques
andré charbonneau radio canada mon frère